I guarantee you
that with this method of manifestation
within 60s a person will contact you about the message
From which you dream
I just checked it myself and it works.
Take your phone in your hand
even now at this moment
and imagine
You are receiving a message from this person.
Imagine the content of this message
imagine a notification
Imagine Bing
on the screen
in hear this voice notification it is very important
hear the voice of this notification in your head
Imagine this message
Imagine its content
imagine a communicator
on which it happens and the face of that person
in this circle on the communicator very
imagine it very strongly
You just have to focus.
Close your eyes or look at the phone.
and with all my heart
Just think about the message from that person
Hear that pink sound
When this message comes
and you just have to visualize with all your heart
that this person is speaking
I don't know EE on Instagram
on messenger
by text what most often you like to communicate
and here is the question of your power and your visualization
and your immense driving power
that you have in your life
So the phone in your hand and imagine how he
She writes to you
sends you a message
You are in contact with this person
and you have to imagine it with all your heart
and hear the sound in my head
Let me know in the comments if it worked.
and I will mark EE the creator with whom I found it
This is not my own technique.
It is fantastically effective.
and share in the language
Polish with you
What I found in English today
I tested and it worked
So if it worked for me
It will work for you too
let me know in a comment